[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
and health man
when i heard you tell that podcast i'm
so glad to know that you were talking to
me because i heard it as if you were
talking to me i told brian callan i go
you ever do a podcast you think joe's
talking to you and he goes all the
[ __ ] time i'm never talking to you
brian gallon
never talking about count i'll call him
up he said no he said he goes one time
joe even said my name
if you think about how ridiculous it is
if people didn't know
that having sex with people has
consequences
uh and and by that i mean you can get
pregnant you can get diseases if there
was no and there's cultural limitations
people frown upon it but if there was
none of those can you imagine how much
people would be [ __ ] oh yeah it would
be insane yeah the the er if there was
no such thing as masturbating you could
[ __ ] at a gas station people would be
[ __ ] yeah if there was no such if
masturbation was impossible first of all
you know what would happen what
women would rule everything
a hundred percent but men would have so
much chi built up in them nope nope
they'd be [ __ ] they'd be giving in
every chance they couldn't because the
women would own it it'd be worth so much
more
that's true yeah because women would be
able to decide whether or not you came
there's the only way if that was the
only way
if women
were the rulers of whether or not you
came if there was no way to come without
them oh my god they would dominate we're
[ __ ] dude i know that's gonna be the
next law if they're really smart that's
how they would take over
chop our arms off
dude what you're telling me though you
wouldn't watch like a little like
chinese guy jerk off from like 30 feet
away go back to this again no but just
watch train accidents i don't want them
to happen
jamie pulls up a video of a train
accident oh my god you got to see this
one [ __ ] okay go ahead uh karen imagine
if your [ __ ] kid's name karen what a
bummer that must be if you're a nice
person named karen and then cameron well
it's like corona beer i mean i can't
believe they had to stop that that that
makes me sad what do you mean they
stopped the name that's what i'm told
they stopped making it i don't know if
that's true that's the source i heard
about i still enjoy a corona i'm not a
[ __ ] child i like corona light but
what am i gonna do and then and then
aids candy that was a smart move you had
to stop that diet candy yeah it makes
you lose weight
it's ironically sad most people don't
even know what we're talking about is
ayds right correct that's what it's
called it was a diet candy like a
chocolate yeah that you would eat i
never took it i mean it's like the ex
slacks for dieting oh is it like a well
xlax actually helps your diet also but
all it does is just get rid of the food
that's in your body it's not healthy no
no i was somewhere once that i was on a
modium because i was having a rough day
i don't know what happened that's
another diuretic right or it's
constipated yeah i mean it's it's it it
it solidifies suppressant candy oh so
it's an appetite suppressant so it's not
a no no it's x-lax
makes you it's a laxative it helps it
makes your [ __ ] diarrhea explosive
explosively if you eat the whole box you
could [ __ ] yourself to death you could
od on it what is barf what is barf bar
that's funny
barbs are detergent is that real
they didn't discontinue it because
people vomit did they find out they
really did discontinue corona beer that
sounds so ridiculous it sounds that's
what i heard from somebody it's a
classic there was also a candy called
anal warts that they decided to take off
the market
you know that's kind of [ __ ] that i
why do i do it you never went there you
couldn't help yourself i could you know
what it is all those years of full house
although i am talking this is not my
podcast this podcast belongs to the one
and only mr chris ryan ladies and
gentlemen uh yay thank you let everybody
know what we're doing this is uh number
three of our uh continuing series of uh
three musketeer podcasts
with joe rogan duncan trussell and yours
truly uh so now we're in we're in joe's
studio actually because uh i don't have
a studio
well we were trying to figure out uh if
we should do our own podcast and we said
no we already have three podcasts let's
just swap off yeah and i like that it's
really we should name them though just
so that people could find them because i
think right a lot of these conversations
are going to deal with some subjects
that maybe they would want to reference
and they would forget which one it was
and we don't want them to have to listen
to right x amount so we should come up
with it i mean three musketeers is too
easy circle jerk
tripod
the triangular i like the three amigos
sounds the three amigos it sounds
i don't know
it sounds unpretentious how about the
lords of truth
well that's that's not pretentious
yeah that's kidding
yeah the spiritual arbiters of the
western world how about shrimp parade
i just wanted to figure out a way to use
what is a shrimp parade i don't know
i have no idea i'd go to one though
i thought that was some sort of uh
reference to our penises but that's
that's that's because you always think
about penis well you were just saying
your podcast was a sausage fest duncan
and then
i wasn't using the term that didn't mean
phallus oh you just talked about that
no i just mean like yeah my podcast
reminds me of a package of
old salty briny
withered sausages that you might find at
a second-hand meat store
what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is a secondhand meat store
it's a guarded old sausage what's this
guy no this
what a great description though
trader joe's is over
i gotta get more girls i gotta get more
girls
gals is what you said sure i said gals
funny though he's trying to be funny
that's the reason the funniest page on
the internet i'm not [ __ ] joker
world's instagram page is the funniest
page in the end
wow man thanks that is so surreal to
hear coming from you uh but we're still
just trying to keep it grow and keep it
moving every day but more importantly
this is like a new thing yeah you're
right it is a new thing there's really
no other accounts promoting comedians
like this right now especially not on
instagram why i'd seen people do like
little things here it is look at this
here's
yeah so here it is joke world on
instagram the link is gonna be in the
bio right now so you can follow it real
quick but basically uh comedians send in
their best 60 second clips to us and
then every day we feature a new up and
coming or less known comedian that right
you know needs a platform which is why
it's so important that everyone who
hears this uh right now goes and follows
that link in the bio our instagram joke
rolled on instagram because you know the
power really comes from the people the
fans of comedy uh the people that are
going to be viewing this video and i
know thousands of people will see this
right so it's a big opportunity for us
to you know create a really powerful
tool in comedy really powerful platform
this is just like a new thing yeah but
people get this uh this new uh
opportunity to do [ __ ] on you know the
internet is so interesting in that way
no that's true it is new and not a lot
of people are getting these
opportunities which is why it's such a
cool thing that any comedian in the
world can send in their best 60 second
clip and then can be seen by our whole
audience i know so that's why it's so
important to make that audience as big
as we can because that's how we're going
to become powerful and how it's going to
become something really special for
these communities to be featured on joke
so it's in the bio right now go click it
and we also send everyone free stickers
who follows and dms us so if you want
any joke world free stickers um then
that's just another reason to follow but
the main reason should be because you
love comedy so just follow right now
live on the podcast following right now
on live on the podcast ladies gentlemen
i'm telling you the this is the funniest
page on the internet yeah it was a guy
and his nose was wedged firmly in this
girl's butt crack and then she saran
wrapped his hair
to her butt and then she did errands and
she walked around the kitchen and she
like turned the sink on and just farting
and she's farting
she's like yeah you like those dirty
farts huh yeah i like anything with
saran wrap
[ __ ] is funny like sack lunch sack lunch
there's this guy that has saran wrap
diaper on and he just the camera just
pans at him and he spreads his cheeks
and fills it
with diarrhea the saran wrap is so funny
you know it's simple but it's good yeah
that's good
just like meals
i just it's the sound it's the timing
it fills up fast
like it pans in just at the right and
then it turns ever so slightly and the
spread and the sound this is something
about someone relishing a woman's farts
like holding onto the cheeks where
there's no oh yeah
yeah
we talked about it for a while and then
people wrote in people wrote in that
we're into it you know because we were
like
and then they would tell us they were
like yeah it goes back to like a pretty
girl making something dirty you know so
it's like oh my gosh i'm so embarrassed
of what i did so they this guy he wrote
in that he was like my uh
now his girl's fiance
like you know knows and is cool and like
whenever she has to fart she calls him
over and he gets so excited
yeah [ __ ] he loves it he loves it
come on how strange are people people
are so strange she earned it that's the
thing about like nicole smith when his
[ __ ] stupid kids wanted his estate no
anna nicole was sucking his dick didn't
you do a bit about this yeah [ __ ] yeah
yeah it's not like closers 1999 was the
whole thing about them saying like oh my
god she's taking advantage of him she's
only being she's only with him for his
money
i'm like don't you think he [ __ ]
knows right that guy made a billion
dollars from scratch
chances are he's a tad crafty and it was
like this whole thing about like how do
you want to die
did you want to die shaking and alone
your hospital bed surrounded by loved
ones or do you want to get a big fat
kentucky fried hooker and just blow it
out
and it was all him dying telling her to
lick his ass and all the different [ __ ]
he did to her right before he died and
the kids have done nothing and they
think they deserve you were raised with
all that [ __ ] money you went to
private schools you had tennis coaches
he probably bought you houses why do you
need more what the [ __ ] did you do you
didn't suck his dick yeah you need to
get your own money stupid right you rode
the ride and now it's over and i think
also
and this sounds [ __ ] up but
that exists because it's a predatory
situation you pray you know if you're a
vulnerable old weak emotional guy who
also has a billion dollars women are
going to prey on you right they're going
to pretend to be something they're not
and they might even convince themselves
that they are that something that
they're pretending to be because their
instinct to try to acquire your wealth
and your social status is so strong that
they want to be the trump girl they want
to be the new girl that trump leaves his
wife for i couldn't imagine being a
woman working in an office with a bunch
of guys trying to [ __ ] you all the time
it's got to be a goddamn nightmare i
can't imagine having a bunch of bosses
that literally tell you you suck my dick
i'll give you a raise yeah that happens
yes [ __ ] it's got to be hell
i get it i mean i get it you have to be
you got to be like an eight though eight
on up to deal with that every day i mean
let's be [ __ ] honest you know what i
mean there's really there's really six
is out there that's really good if
you've got a person's name a lot
got a nice ass
there were four pigs that lived in the
house and one of them was whitney
cummings pig and they brought whitney
cummings pig out to me and gay and i
held it and it squealed like i was
[ __ ] it
but i totally wasn't i totally wasn't i
totally wasn't but
i definitely did not watch that man [ __ ]
my wife
i already don't believe you
i already don't believe you
oh that's a powerful statement
oh so anyway then there's that story for
years i've been shocked even with this
platform i'm like how is there one guy
that can speak to the whole world
and the us government isn't [ __ ]
surveilling you and having drones
everywhere watch the show it's like
anyone can get it oh that's a good point
you're not hiding
no that's the
it's like there's freedom in uh exposing
yes
you can really be free if you just give
also i'm a [ __ ] cage fighting
commentator who's
dude what if your deep state that was
really your smoke screen
imagine if you just got really good at
these things just so you could be deep
state
you the problem is that's not how people
get good at things right you get things
from no motivation you'd never be able
to compete with guys
really hustling yeah you have to be
really hustling
and then they bring you to [ __ ] island
for me sex is the one thing that
completely focuses my mind uh and and
rock climbing which i did once and it's
the last time i whimpered
uh i would imagine that that would
[ __ ] put a pucker in your little butt
hole yeah yeah anything what puts a
pucker in your butthole
[Laughter]
yeah no rock climbing is intense i mean
anything scuba diving you know anything
where your body's convinced you're about
to die really focuses your mind all
right well i don't feel like i'm gonna
die when i'm having sex i'm just doing
it wrong well but sex for me i mean
especially when i was younger i i used
to try to think about other things just
to stop from coming yeah and you know
what worked for me
old people in snow
that's that was the only thing that
worked
[Laughter]
old people in yellow snow dogs oh people
trudging through the snow maybe that
should be our podcast old people don't
know
that's not a bad idea it sounds like
we're doing blow or something
old people on snow on snow it's the only
thing that kept chris ryan from coming
as a child from like from like 14 to 27.
yeah yeah those are the years i thought
about you two weeks ago when i went to
cvs
and i saw a white guy
and a hot african-american chick having
an argument outside of cvs
at 9 20 in the morning he was a little
chubby
and they were having some type of loud
discussion i went and i got my
medication when i walked out he's
yelling that i want my wallet back you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
why'd you think of me because
because
a lot of people use used and used stand
up to get a show to get a writing gig to
get something and i'm like i can't stop
being one i am one yeah that's part of
my hard drive well it was the most fun
too like they were asking me to do this
thing that i was basically like i never
taken any acting classes i had i'd just
gotten a development deal from mtv half
hour comedy hour right and they said do
you want to be on a sitcom i'm like oh
okay and so they made me like get an
acting coach and i took a few classes
but it was really annoying and then next
thing you know i'm out here in la on a
sitcom and so when they said like why
are you doing stand-up you're in action
i was like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about right you don't you've never
killed i'm like you're saying this
because you never killed they also
didn't believe in hyphenates at that
point you can't do three things you
can't do four things i'm sorry you can
only do one thing that was awesome then
i started working for the ufc and when i
started working for the ufc they were
acting like i was doing porn
they're like what are you doing and i
was like yeah i'm going to alabama to do
uh post fight interviews for a cage
fighting event you know what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you because you're
they don't know what that is i've seen
both i've seen i've seen people get
victimized and i've seen people that are
just in sort of this relationship where
i wouldn't want it but it works for them
you know sometimes they're out in the
open with it the woman will tease and be
like oh honey you know i wouldn't be
with you if it wasn't for the [ __ ]
money oh it's not even a team he goes of
course i know that that's a movie that's
in a movie what was the movie that was
in there was a movie that was in where
the tune well no the schindler's list
terms of endeavors you can't even help
it you do it right away
[ __ ] platoon there's a picture in
organs hanging out on on the beach
um i forget the movie man uh but it was
just about
about a guy who lost everything
and in the scene like his his wife was
like laughing about it when everything
was going great and then when he did
lose all the money she did [ __ ] leave
him hey well actually it was in the wolf
of wall street too it's a common theme
and the wolf of wall street obviously it
was a crazy coked up [ __ ] maniac
piece of [ __ ] but when he was going
under and his business was going under
that's when the wife left him when he
was doing great the wife wanted him when
he was married to another woman yeah i
mean like it was it was a classic story
so it's not like that's an unfamiliar
paradigm to us it's nature it's a
wounded antelope that gets taken out by
the the lion
and she needs somebody to provide for
her or she doesn't but in that role she
does if she chooses that role if she
chooses the role of [ __ ] the old
wrinkly
shaky man with his [ __ ] pale
translucent dick that he sticks inside
we could see as he's coming you'd see
the veins like pump
whatever blood they've
got and it's like a little highway going
down his [ __ ] saran wrap skin filled
with viagra yeah and just shooting dust
bubbles into her [ __ ] yeah
yeah man i mean that's something
you can take that choice or you know you
could start an art gallery and become a
multi-millionaire on your own i mean you
could do that too you know it's but when
you are that girl okay if you are that
25 year old girl with an adderall
problem that's looking to try to hook up
with some old billionaire dude and marry
him so he'd be taking care of her life
you're that that's your role that's what
you've chosen you might have more
potential than that but it doesn't mean
that that's not what you've chosen oh
you don't even know baby she's so slick
she's so smart i mean that is one of the
smartest girls i've ever met in my life
when she met him and she put out
together it doesn't matter okay you're
talking nonsense she's still that girl
she's a problem you can't say no no
listen you can't say she's a prostitute
because i know her and she's powerful
and what she did was you know she's
really clever and she figured a way to
manipulate guys no no she's still
prostituted right you're missing the
whole point right it doesn't matter if
she has all this potential she reads 150
books a week okay don't [ __ ] tell me
that girl is so goddamn smart oh my god
you're saying she's not smart no
she's a hooker all right she's playing
the role of a hooker sometimes in the
podcast i'll like uh shout out to people
who sent me emails interesting that's a
terrible idea i should cease that at
once well all right i'll cease it right
right after i do this one
jack william verbernet verburn or
however he says it he lives in new
zealand had a shitty job he wrote to say
i me emailed you last year asking for
advice
you didn't feel comfortable but you said
something and you said to me the only
way to fly is to jump so i thought i'd
email you again and tell you that
because of listening to you and duncan
and joe i'm now paralyzed
i found out about airplanes you're full
of [ __ ] man the only way to fly is get
on a [ __ ] airplane have you seen king
ash rippers work um excuse me
dude please pick him up what is that
this guy we've reached out a lot offered
him and he yes just because he's such a
creative guy what are you talking maybe
you could get him maybe the great joe
rogan could get
your powers king ass ripper ass ripper
yeah harry and gross
lord of all farts and gluttony he makes
videos oh no i love him so this is him
yeah king asked oh please give me some
volume
that's still
[Music]
oh no okay he is moving
[Music]
is that real
yes oh go to ripon massive farts yeah go
to ripon
what's up with his pants yeah he
it's does stupid
it's getting brown it's got 199 000 hits
yeah how many [ __ ] stand-up bits
online have 199 000. that's mine
even with elon's like you reach a
certain level you must have
look if i'm the guy if i'm deep state
right and i would know we got this smart
south african dude right and he can
invent anything he can do all this cool
[ __ ] and i'm going to be like all right
yeah bring him over here and he's like
oh maybe i want to go you know sell some
[ __ ] to saudi arabia and i'll be like
maybe you don't
right
yeah and he's like yeah just as simple
as that he's like i'm gonna go on joe
rogan's podcast and smoke weed you're
like do whatever the [ __ ] you want we
don't care about the stock prices i
think they're trying to improve what a
person is what i think we're doing oh by
chopping our son's balls off
[Music]
you